in other news tonight a henderson woman
is being recognized for her work
advocating for abused and neglected
children she's a court-appointed special
advocate also known as casa joe muller
introduces us to carolyn maskari who has
a message for others about this program
i've always believed that the only
important thing in the world are people
with walls full of family photos and the
most vulnerable are children it's
obvious carolyn maskari loves her family
our job is to advocate for their best
interests for four decades mascari has
shared her love with more than just her
family i always tell everybody it's the
best paying job i ever had but not in
money she has been a casa for 40 years
that is a court appointed special
advocate and what we do is advocate for
children in the foster care system who
have been abused or neglected
in the court we have we advocate for
them in the court to do what is in their
best interest she is the longest serving
casa in the country and because of that
work the national organization
recognized her at a ceremony in seattle
when i heard about it i was kind of
blown away to tell you the truth there
are 90 over 93 000 classes nationwide
and i've been the longest serving she
says it was bittersweet winning the
award we were married for 57 years her
husband was her biggest supporter he
always was very very supportive very
encouraging but he passed away months
ago he made me to be what i was able to
do i felt like i couldn't have done it
without the support of my family now she
has a message for the rest of us i just
really would like to see us get more
cautious we just really really
need more causes she hopes more people
can volunteer their time
don't plan to ever stop joe muller live
local now for more information on how to
volunteer visit our website eight news
now dot